Fools Rush In Where Angels Fear To Tread
a leopard doesn't change its spots
never trouble trouble until trouble
troubles you
from Little acorns Mighty Oaks do grow
God helps those who help themselves
where there's a will there's a way
[Music]
a ship in the harbor is safe but that's
not what ships are made for
[Music]
darkest before the dawn
always put your best foot forward
when one door shuts another opens
good things come to those who wait
foreign
take it with a grain of salt
bitter pills may have blessed effects
there is no time like the present
The Vessel makes a lot of noise
don't make a mountain out of a mole hill
grief shared is made lighter
[Music]
an idle mind is the devil's workshop
Time and Tide wait for no man
honesty is the best policy
an ounce of protection is worth a pound
of cure
hope for the best prepare for the worst
a thing begun is half done
if it ain't broke don't fix it
barking dogs seldom bite
if wishes were horses Beggars would ride
slow and choosing but slower and
changing
if you can't beat them join them
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
better to be safe than sorry
Beggars can't be choosers
it's easy to be wise after the event
the best things in life are free
it's never too late to mend
[Music]
better to be poor and healthy than rich
and sick
it's no use crying over spilled milk
better to wear out than to rust out
[Music]
learn to walk before you run
practice what you preach
the coward dies a thousand deaths the
brave but one
discretion is the better part of valor
[Music]
let sleeping dogs lie
don't bite off more than you can chew
look before you leap
[Music]
don't bite the hand that feeds you
necessity is the mother of invention
don't cast your pearls before the swine
[Music]
no pain no gain
don't count your chickens before they
hatch
[Music]
no news is good news
you can't judge a book by its cover
[Music]
Once Bitten Twice Shy
every cloud has a silver lining
one man's trash is another man treasure
[Music]
every man is the architect of his
destiny
sword
familiarity breeds contempt
persuasion is better than Force
[Music]
all the Glitters Is Not Gold
practice makes perfect
all's fair in Love and War
adversity and loss make a man wise
silence is half consent
a fool in his money are soon parted
slow and steady wins the race
when the going gets tough the tough get
going
a journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with a single step
Still Waters Run Deep
a chain is only as strong as its weakest
link
Mariah
a bad Workman always blames his tools
the harder you work the luckier you get
a bird in the hand is worth two in the
bush
proof of the pudding is in the eating
there is safety in numbers
makes the heart grow fonder
[Music]
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions
[Music]
louder than words
too many cooks spoil the broth
a drowning man will clutch at a straw
watch The Donut not the hole
[Music]
what goes around comes around
give them an inch and they'll take a
mile
[Music]